we have some really interesting thermal
testing for our GTX 1080 TI review today
that's this thing right here Torn to
Pieces as it so happens we'll be going
through those metrics thermals versus
frequency mostly alongside the usual
gaming benchmarks and then we have some
synthetics Linked In the description
below in the article where there's a bit
more depth on everything about this card
before getting to the review this
coverage is brought to you by thermal
take and their Tower 900 display case
this case has glass panel all around and
is an excellent option for full custom
water Loops which if you're buying a
card that's $700 you might be in the
market for Link in the description below
for more information going over price
first again the 1080ti is a $700 MSRP
Partners can ship above that but the
founders Edition still called that the
reference card basically is still going
to be 700 so they've removed the special
Founders edition price that cost so much
confusion with a 1080 launch so that's a
good thing this is 700 dead for the Fe
version and MSRP with that announcement
came the announcement of reduced MSRP
for the GTX 1080s there are already
today on newag Amazon wherever $500 GTX
1080s including $530 evjcc models if
you're looking a little bit overclocked
or gigabyte models for 500 flat so the
1080s are already dropped 1080 TI is on
the way and aib partner models of this
card we're reviewing today should be
available within a few weeks pretty
short L actually because this has been
kind of in the winds for a while now in
the meantime we're looking at the
reference version all of these cards
ultimately are built on the new gp102
die if you wanted the full identifier
it's gp102 d350
dk1 and that's for the die underneath
the cooler of course and we've already
taken the card apart for a few projects
which you'll see over the next few days
this block diagram of the GTX 1080ti
shows its layout broken into six gpcs or
Graphics processing clusters in a
similar fashion in some ways to how the
GP 100 is broken up though with some
pretty important differences in SM
layout the focus is removed from
anything but fp32 with the GTX 1080ti
and we have 128 fp32 cicor per SM just
like all the other Pascal cards in the
gaming line when counting a total of 28
SMS times 128 we're at 3584 cicor in
total the GTX 1080 GP 104 chip hosts 20
SMS which total at 2560 cores so about
1,000 cores over the GTX 1080 this seems
to align with nvidia's marketing claims
that the 1080 TI increases performance
by 35% over the 1080 that launched in
May of last year that will be validating
those claims throughout this video the
rest of the block diagram is familiar
we're faced with 224 tmus and a base
clock of 1480 MHz or boost 1582 and that
results in a texture filter rate of 3544
gigatex per second at the Boost clock we
have a video on the channel already if
you're not sure what that means a total
of 88 RS are present on the card
compared to 64 on the GTX 1080 a bit of
an upgrade there and if you start
totaling these things up gp102 in some
ways looks familiar to the GP 100 it's
got the same tmu count the same GPC
count but they're still again
significantly different in their targets
GP 100 of course is built for
acceleration not for Consumer Graphics
certainly not for gaming in any way and
this means that Precision on GP 100
splits itself between 32 16 64
capabilities whereas 102 focuses on fp32
applications gp102 is also a bigger die
than the GP 104 which was 314 mm squ
that's the 1080 and GP 102 measures in
at 471 mm squ which helps accommodate
the additional SMS eight additional SM
so a bigger die area since we're getting
on a plane in about 6 hours from filming
this we're going to jump straight to the
benchmarks for the benchmarks today
we're using a fully rebuilt GPU test
bench for 2017 I believe this is the
first I know this is the first GPU
review other than the icx card of 2017
that gives us an opportunity to move to
the
i77700k which has a higher top end more
headro in frame rate than the 5930k we
we were using previously and it also
means that we can refresh our suite of
games and other applications being
tested including some new automation
done by Patrick lean in house that's
really exciting now this also means for
all of the excitement with a new test
bed we lose some data and that's
unfortunate so everything on the
previous tests can't really compare it
anymore it's a different platform
different memory different drives uh
different testing methodology for the
games Doom we've changed how we tested a
bit and we've added new games so that
means that we lose things like the Titan
XP comparison since that was on loan to
us uh so we don't have that for you
today unfortunately but we do have new
numbers for the 1080 1070
980ti reference cards the 1080ti
reference card and then one rx48 just to
throw it in there as a representative of
the $250 market so in the article below
we'll have the testing methodology as
always we'll also have numbers for
future Mark testing like 3D Mark fire
strike and time spy moving forward we're
refreshing our GPU bench with the
relevant high and contenders first as
listed with a splash from the $250
Market represented Again by the 480 note
also that the 480 competes in a
completely different price bracket so
we're not really going to pay too much
attention to it it's just there in case
you want an idea of where Things Fall
We'll add Vega of course once it's ready
and we'll slowly add more gpus to this
bench with each content piece including
aib models if you're curious about those
and one final note here because of the
limited time between packs ryzen and
other events we are going to be visiting
overclocking and noise testing
separately so those won't make it into
this piece unfortunately uh but they
will be in a piece post packs our
thermal tests are up first for these
benchmarks we're measuring mosfet
temperature in the middle of the board
and at the bottom of the the board so
that'll be fets number two and 7even on
the 1080 TI on the icx GTX 1080 or fets
number one and five on the GTX 1080 Fe
card counting bottom up and those are
measured with our thermocouples they are
K types they're calibrated in boiling
and ice water as normally and we have
some more information on exactly what
those things are in the article let's
start with just the 1080ti then add
other cards for now we can see GPU
temperatures in the 84 to 85c range with
mosfets number 7 and two close packed
around 65 to 68c this is actually
heavily competitive to a partner fet
temperatures but the card is also only
stock clock loads and the GPU
temperature of course looks dismal when
compared to aibb Partners the card
requires a significantly higher fan
speed in order to sustain a comparable
GPU temperature to what will be possible
on aib partners and we can say that
confidently because of previous
experience with the 1080 and of course
you sacrifice noise output on the 1080
TI Fe version if you want to achieve
those temperatures to this end despite
using high quality materials externally
and internally the cooler is actually
not all that great for our audience it's
a better fit for system integrators iy
power cyber power at all and if you have
specific needs maybe sfff it could fit
there as well we're still recommending
axial or liquid coolers for the most
part though because you're choking on
the clock in a way which is unnecessary
with the Fe cooler that's where aib
vendors come in of course to fix things
here's a comparison to the GTX 1080 Fe
for frame of reference to the last gen
of coolers from the Pascal lineup we're
seeing the GPU temperatures on each
device locked to their Max permissible
limit when under stock settings with the
fet temperatures all within the same
range that's actually a good thing the
GTX 1080 fe's middle mosfet does run
about a Celsius warmer 1° Celsius or so
than the GTX 1080 TI's middle mosfet but
the card cools effectively identically
one under a high stress workload and of
course these aren't the same fets
they're not in the same place so that
does impact things as well the
measurement is not perfect what matters
is the frequency throughput though and
that is a perfect measurement since both
cards are boosting to a point of hitting
thermal limits looking at the clock rate
versus temperature we can reveal that
the 1080t is able to sustain a higher
more stable clock when forcing its fan
to 80% this enters into territory of
unbearable noise and does not
representative of a sustainable user
scenario without a noise damping box of
some kind Maybe shoved into a basement
but it does show how the Silicon behaves
when temperature is no longer a concern
the GPU frequency on the 1080ti with
auto fan speeds or around 50% shows that
we're bouncing rapidly between about
1341 pretty low to about 15 to 44 MHz by
contrast the 1080ti at manual 80% fan
speed posts frequency almost at a
constant 1480 MHz with occasional spikes
to around 1544 note that this is with a
VM power virus scenario so we're seeing
higher thermals despite a lower clock
overall that is expected behavior and
this clock rate is not representative of
what you would see in a video game just
to stick one of our ancient charts back
up here that we've now changed
methodology to accommodate fet
temperatures these temperatures show at
a steady state so we're looking at how
the GPU performs in terms of thermals
once it has been left alone under heavy
load for a long period of time the
1080ti reference ends up around 58 C
delta T for its steady state temperature
when under torture workloads and with an
auto fan control the Fe version of the
1080 meanwhile it's around 57.5 C that's
well within our measurement variance and
so we must say that the 1080 Fe
alongside the 980ti and 1080ti are
effectively equal in thermal performance
Nvidia claimed 5 Celsius improvements
with the 1080ti layout but we can't
exactly validate that on the same PCB
which is important because one GPU
binning two different GPU three
different vrm uh we can't validate it
exactly because we don't have a means to
fit both coolers on the same card at
least within a reasonable amount of time
the changes to fets vrms all that means
it's not exactly an Apples to Apples
comparison but we are not seeing a 5
Celsius reduction stock you might see it
if you match the clock rates or
something like that if you're curious
how an aib partner board Compares our
previous EVGA icx review gives a good
look at those numbers in general for
thermals you should expect the same
highish to high temperatures for these
reference designs for the 1080ti as with
previous reference designs from both
Nvidia and AMD Nvidia is not alone here
neither is AMD they both make reference
designs that are versatile they're good
for SI they're good for other sectors of
the market but for our audience for most
of you doing system builds DIY style
you're going to be better off with an
aib partner model that cools quieter and
better or at least in the very least
quieter for the same and that's really
not a bad tradeoff this cooler is not
particularly impressive but neither was
the 1080 fees cooler despite that
nvidia's marketing did show in its
presentation when Jensen was on stage in
San Francisco they showed a 2038 maximum
clock rate with temperatures below
85c that may be possible in their test
environment we were not able to
replicate that in our testing without
making the fan speeds so high that they
make your ears bleed which may be the
case just like with the 1080 in Austin
if maybe that the card was in a box
somewhere in a back room at 100% fan
speed because then you I could see those
temperatures being possible but
otherwise I don't know that the 50% more
bearable fan speed will make that a
reality if you do need a reference board
for liquid blocks for example consider
waiting for board vendors to ship their
stripped down versions with the same PCB
with disposable plastic coolers because
those might be a bit cheaper or include
rebates at least to drag cost down a bit
moving on to FPS we're starting with a
brand new game to our bench Ghost Recon
using the built-in Benchmark and set to
very high preset at 4K 1440 and 1080p we
are looking at GPU performance first
with 4K at 4K the 1080 TI pushes an
average frame rate of 55 FPS with 1%
lows at 45 and 0.1% lows at 42
comparatively the 1080 Fe card runs
about 10 FPS lower in all values for a
difference in average frame rate of
approximately 29% that's not exactly the
35% number that was thrown around
everywhere but it's pretty damn close
the GTX 1070 reference card lands around
35 FPS average for the same test for a
performance Improvement of about 58%
when moving from the 1070 to the 1080 TI
as for the last gen comparison the 980
TI reference card post performance
around 34 FPS average at 4K which is
really dragging into territory of being
stuttery in this title you could get
away with 4cat lower settings of course
but not with the setup shifting to 1440p
we see the GTX 1080ti operating at 91
FPS average with lows tightly timed at
74 and 66 FPS that looks good in terms
of the frame time consistency the GTX
1080 is just under 20 FPS lower than
that at 74 FPS average with lows also
fairly close at least to the ti at 61
and 54 the Improvement here from the
1080 reference card is about
22.5% as for the GTX 107 Fe the
performance Improvement is about 47 FPS
from the GTX 1070 to the GTX 1080ti Fe
cards moving us between 62 and 91
average with a 980 TI at 1440p we're
seeing a performance Improvement of
around 60% generationally that's at 57
FPS average certainly playable the rx480
is on here but again with these settings
being at very high and 1440p it's not
really targeted to Benchmark these
mid-range cards it's a bit unfair if
you're looking at 1440p for a mid-range
card you'd have to drop your settings
and it would still be playable just drop
the settings but Doom is where we really
start seeing things get a bit
interesting our Doom benchmarking has
ditched openg GL for comparison entirely
mostly to make time for other tests and
instead pushes to strictly rely on
Vulcan for the test API of choice we're
also Now using ultra settings for
graphics with anti-aliasing disabled and
async turned on so you get that extra
boost you can find more in the article
below at 4K Doom position the 1080ti at
around 90 FPS average with lows close
behind and in the 70s the GTX 1080 Fe
card stands around 68 average resulting
in an improvement of about 33% to the ti
the 1070 was never really a 4K gaming
device but it's holding on respectably
well with doom at these settings we're
just under 60 FPS average and could make
tweaks to go over 60 the difference is
about 60 to 64% improvement with the
1080ti but of course that price is also
about a 2X increase the GTX 980 TI
performs at 49 FPS average at these
settings and is mostly playable with the
help of Doom's engine optimizations you
can make a few tweaks though looking now
at 1440p the GTX 1080ti is bumping
against the limitations of Doom's frame
rate and that is an engine limitation
Doom limits itself to 200 FPS due to a
physics bug and so frame rates that
exceed 200 FPS aren't really seen
they're capped this skews numbers in a
way that makes the higher end cards
capable of exceeding 200 look a little
bit lower in the charts and just like a
bottleneck would do the only difference
here is that rather than a CPU or GPU
bottleneck we have one that's not too
commonly discussed an engine bottleneck
we see these in GTA 5 for Quad thread
testing at 187.5 FPS as well for similar
engine reasons we're starting to really
illustrate generational differences here
with the 980ti nearly doubled in
performance by the 1080ti just to really
illustrate this Frame cap and doom let's
look at 1080p with this our average is a
steady 200 FPS with lows no worse than
175 0.1% the GTX 1080 isn't far from
this at 190 and Performing effectively
equally since they're both bottlenecked
by the game engine the 1070 hits 200
less frequently and is measurably behind
of course you would really for the most
part play at these types of settings
unless you have a 200 HZ display but it
does show generational scaling better to
the 980 TI since that was even more
common when it shift moving to for Honor
one of our new titles added we're
testing with extreme settings across all
three main resolutions at 4K and extreme
the 1080 TI is finally able to crack 60
FPS in the game though just barely we're
at 66 average with 60 FPS 1% low and 57
0.1% lows you could get a 1080 to
similar Heights given an aftermarket
card and some tuning but we're talking
about a drop of maybe one tick in
settings to get there the gtx980ti is
entering unplayable territory with these
settings right alongside the rx480 you
would need settings reductions or just
really honestly drop the resolution and
doing that dropping to 14 40p the story
changes a bit now something like an
rx480 would be an excellent choice at
its price point roughly 250 if you
wanted 1440p gaming with near Max
settings a slight reduction would help
frame times but we're looking at the
1080 TI today anyway and the GTX 980ti
for a generational look at that still
holds its ground well against the new
Polaris and Pascal cards but posts an
improvement of about 54 FPS by moving to
the 1080 TI or around 70% the GTX 1080
is plenty playable here with nearly 100
FPS average in tight frame times using
ashes for another dx12 look configured
the high settings GPU focus on 4K we're
seeing the 1080 TI land at 99 FPS
average with the 1080 reference at 79 or
about a 25% Improvement to the 1080ti
really not hitting that magic 35% figure
in this test though the jump from the
1070 is naturally a lot higher though so
is the jump in price again looking at an
improvement of about 62% to the ti our
final Benchmark game is Sniper Elite 4
this was recommended by AMD for the
bench we spoke to both Nvidia and AMD
and gave them both an option to
recommend one game for the bench Nvidia
liked Ghost Recon AMD liked Sniper Elite
so we added each although we're not
looking in depth at AMD cards today that
time will soon come at 4K and with high
settings with async enabled and dx12 the
1080 TI operates a frame rate of about
76 FPS average pretty damn high for 4K
but sniper isn't the most graphically
intensive game on the market the 1080
reference card sits at a hard 60 FPS
with lows dipping into the 40s this is
still just fine for gameplay and we're
not able to start seeing more visible
stutters until jumping to the 1070
considering 4K is more of a 1080 or TI
class config the 1070 holds well on its
own at 48 we'll have to see how AMD does
on this bench shortly as it should be
favorable for the Polaris and Vega gpus
given an async and dx12 focus given that
we're sandwiched between PS East in a
few hours and ryzen coverage and the
ryzen event and the viia event and other
events this review still has some things
I'd like to add to it like noise noise
is one of the things we're overall we're
not recommending an Fe reference design
anyway if you were to buy a 1080ti it
should probably be a partner model so
the noise tests would be nice to further
back that up and show things objectively
but they'll be have to be added after
packs in addition to this you may have
noticed that overclocking wasn't a major
Focus we have one overclocking number
with fire strike extreme on the website
but I was having some stability issues
during overclocking in the last few
hours before getting on this next plane
so we scrapped it it'll have to come in
the next content post probably right
after packs so there are still a few
things to look at overclocking was the
same process as always it just didn't
happen to be stable when we were working
with this card and that's really a
matter of some more fine-tuning so we
need time for that stock performance
overall though of the GTX 1080 is still
more than enough if you own one of those
don't bother upgrading to a 1080 TI
unless you have a very specific need
it's more of a side grade so unless
you're able to split the difference and
trade in with a manufacturer Nvidia sort
of is competing with Itself by dropping
the GTX 1080s in price anyway to $500
since that card can also handle 4K with
some settings tuning and handles 1440p
without much trouble at all the bigger
argument you could make would be for
high refresh gaming as the 1080 TI fills
that Niche where others have fallen
short though have gotten quite close
1440p at 144 Herz is doable in some of
these games like for Honor if you're
okay with dropping to high or very high
from extreme in that case assuming no
anti-aliasing for owners of a GTX 980ti
this is a sizable upgrade and in some
cases it's a pretty damn big jump if you
want those higher resolutions if you're
not on higher resolutions maybe don't
bother there's still mileage left in the
980ti it's the 780ti that's the most
interesting to look at but again
unfortunately because of time that
wasn't added yet still based on just
extrapolating performance that's
probably where an upgrade makes the most
immediate sense it just comes down to
what resolution you're trying to use so
the main reason to buy a Founders
Edition card as always is going to be
the reference PCB there will be other
reference PCB cards but this is the
first one if you want it it'll be out
there
ekwb already has plans for water blocks
compatible with this PCB the 1080 Fe
water blocks won't work it's a different
board different vrm layout but there are
plans already for water blocks in the
works we've spoken with them about that
otherwise wait on Partner models for
cool reasons uh and for potentially
custom pcbs potentially better
overclocking we've also got build Zoid
working on a vrm analysis of this board
this is quite a bit different from the
108 1080 so for this board we're looking
at a vrm that is uh doing some doubling
action so you've got two fats per phase
which does spread out the heat a little
bit so that would help explain why the
vrm temperatures on this board are
actually really good they're comparable
to an icx video card the ones VJ just
launched and uh that's a good thing the
place that falls behind is GPU cooling
as expected and as seen in the past but
the vrm design uh does spread out heat a
bit and helps in that scenario as for
whether it's worth buying this is sort
of a weird Market position right now
where Nvidia exists largely uncontested
and these last major cards in this type
of Market were the fury X and uh Fury
cards and the rx480 is the newest thing
that they have and it's an extremely
strong competitor at the 200 250ish
price point that's a pretty good winner
it holds that market very strongly while
AMD is waiting on Vega so they're in a
good position for the mid-range they
just don't have anything at the high end
yet which makes this a weird thing to
review because not a lot of competition
so what we can say is that the 1080ti if
you don't need an upgrade now today if
you're not building a system this week
or something like that it's probably
worth looking into if you're looking at
a high Budget Car that said the 1080
does sort of compete with the 1080 TI if
you don't need those 144 120 Herz
refresh hits you can drop down to a 1080
it's still a damn good card and you save
a lot of money you can put that money
towards something better in the system
like better ssds or something like that
if you do need to upgrade today there's
no shame there should be no remorse in
buying a 108ti 1080 something like that
Vega will come we will review it it's
just a matter of when at this point we
know first half and that's really all we
know in terms of specifics there's
there's not out there so Vega will be
compared eventually the rx480 still
looks good at the $250 price point we
would recommend that in that category
the 1060 is good but look between the
two and figure out what games you're
playing because they have advantages the
480 at its price is very competitive
1070 is still good 1080 is still good
1080 TI is great for its gains it
doesn't always have that 35% number uh
but overall it's a good card it's it's
just a matter of getting better cooling
on the thing so it can perform to its
full potential which is something we're
doing if you can't tell by this setup so
uh as always go to patreon.com Gamers
Nexus to help us out directly Gamers
nexus.net for the full review like
comment subscribe all that stuff quick
shout out for anyone who wants 3440 X
1440p benchmarks 1440 I guess if you
want those Ultra wide benchmarks one of
our uh friends of the site Tech ga.com
will have that stuff he does it where I
don't so check him out if you want the
ultra wide stuff I trust his numbers
we'll see you all next time